[Music]
ah
we do have a guest merch can you set it
up and i'll put it on put him on the
screen uh
yeah he got a little heat last week from
the new hampshire libertarian twitter
account by uh posting some
truth i guess
uh as i described him before he went to
break i think the second or third most
famous libertarian at this point
probably uh reid coverdale what's going
on man what's going on dude uh a lot
although it's it's finally cooled down
the beginning of this week was a little
crazy but uh we're doing good everything
everything's good
man that was [ __ ] wild dude and now
you've been part of uh this
sort of uh movement of um young
libertarians that uh aren't
very well liked by
libertarians
i would say right uh are you so you're
part of like because i see you do a lot
of stuff with dave smith and uh clint
and all those guys like so you're part
of that whole
like little bit of an uprising that's
been going on right
yeah although we kind of control things
now the it's the mises caucus was kind
of the underdogs and they took over the
party but i'm part of the new hampshire
libertarian party where we're even we're
like more extreme than the mises caucus
like we sometimes make the mises caucus
go whoa guys whoa easy like but uh yeah
our job is like kind of push the overton
window shock people into new
conversations and as you see it uh it
was effective this weekend for sure oh
real quick guy that ran like i'm sorry
it's 10 like 10 years ago he ran daryl
something and
daryl perry that's his name he's the one
who's got the best quote of all time
because he's like they were talking
about driver's licenses
what's next a license to operate a damn
toaster oven
he was like super libertarian i don't
even think we should have driver's
licenses i don't think we should pay
insurance for anything like that yeah
that was so funny and the union leader
uh they were criticizing us for the
mccain tweet and saying like we lost all
credibility uh we've gone from running a
serious governor campaign in new
hampshire wants to this and the they're
referencing the darrell perry run for
governor in new hampshire so that's as
serious as we have been and then we
suddenly just lost all of our
credibility that you know we totally had
with the mainstream media after you know
john brennan called us terrorists and
domestic extremists at the beginning of
last year so i don't know it's funny to
see how people have reacted to it i like
this the uh there's no bottom for the
republican party this is
dude this honestly was one where i was
like howling i mean you know a lot of
people say like when they say i was
really i know i was actually laughing at
one point i was explaining to my wife
the original tweet because she asked me
what's going on and i'm explaining it to
her and i'm crying laughing while i'm
saying and then she goes do people get
mad i go oh people got mad
it was dude and the problem with this is
is like
with this tweet because everyone's
giving you [ __ ] and it's like well this
no this this is how you get attention
and this is the right way to [ __ ] do
it look i don't want to blow up your
spot but can i tell can i just say what
your other twitter is the one i sent the
link to her no
uh yeah why not i have been banned bro
bro you want to talk
hey merch i didn't even tell mercies
because you told me like during the
break while i was you know looking at
the thing hey merge he tells me hey send
me the zoom link to my other twitter
account i'm like okay it's at it's
at ulysses liberty it's a uss liberty
twitter page
and i know now i know it's you because i
actually like something from this the
other day because it was so funny
very funny google the description is
google uss liberty 1967
and dancing
bro that's [ __ ] funny
yeah exactly
so it's just funny like
the problem is is all these people talk
tough right like everyone everyone talks
tough but the moment you expo this
exposes all of them right where it's
like so you don't care you all call
these you all call each other war
criminals all the time right you call
each other out all the time you don't
mean it because everybody everybody
everybody everybody wants to talk about
people are war criminals until it's time
to get rid of war criminals you know
then all of a sudden then everyone's
like whoa hey
oh i'm like and and the the megan mccain
things one of the the one that got me
really mad because there was a lot of
people that were a lot of republicans
[ __ ] [ __ ] that were saying too
that were like um
oh she's not her father i'm like bro she
co-signed everything her father did she
covered every up everything he did and
she went on a [ __ ] viewing on news
programs all the time to say how awesome
and braver that is so go [ __ ] yourself
uh oh yeah yeah yeah i mean totally i
mean megan mccain the idea that she's
just like a waitress or some like you
know completely innocent relative of
john mccain is ridiculous i mean you've
seen the my father compilation of her
i'm sure yeah has she's done nothing but
grift off of his existence and his death
her entire career and i think she even
credits him
to joining the view in the first place
like she joined the view because she
wanted to basically normalize his
neo-conservative message to middle-age
soccer moms and you know she thinks the
january 6th protesters belong in gitmo
uh she thinks that julian assange should
rot in prison you know so yeah [ __ ] this
lady the idea that she's not just an
extension of him is ridiculous and
you're right like this this exposed a
lot of people a lot of conservatives and
not just like establishment
conservatives but some people who like
to think they're like anti-establishment
conservatives because what it is is you
usually have like a you have a
purposeful
um intentional narrative and then
there's an intentional counter-narrative
that you're kind of
permitted to run against the official
narrative that they don't like really
give you a hard time for so you can talk
about how ridiculous it is that
transgender women are on the swim team
or whatever like you could talk about
how that's stupid but there are certain
things you they don't want you to talk
about like if you start saying that like
taiwan is the same thing as what's going
on in ukraine you know then all the
people who are supposedly anti-war you
know then they like jump on you like
what like are you part of the ccp are
you blah blah blah you know are you all
this it's like we're we hate war
criminals we hate people who want to you
know drag us into this [ __ ] and we think
that the scum of the earth we think
they're stalin hitler mao you know
whatever they're the same thing they're
not these heroes that we've come to just
you know basically worship in our daily
life so shocking people into this
conversation with yes a tweet that was
in bad taste like people keep telling us
this is disgusting or this is in bad
taste it's like
yes that was the point yeah now you're
talking about it yeah and the bad
tasting's always funny to me because
it's like
first off that's [ __ ] depending on
who you listen if you're somebody who
lost a kid because they [ __ ] bombed
the hospital over there you probably
don't think it's in bad taste you
probably want to see him and his
daughter's entire family [ __ ] rotten
hell so it really is all perspective
and i i just want to make the argument
you know and i understand that uh mccain
has a checkered past and
um understatement i understand that he's
he made some mistakes and that may have
cost some lives here yeah but uh you
know counterpoint to what you just said
uh have you ever considered the fact
that if uh we're not fighting him over
there uh we gotta fight him over here
have you been compromised by sean heavy
have you been compromised by sean
hannity that's my favorite argument
though i love that one it's like bro if
we're not if we're not murdering all
these people over there and making their
sons angry and they don't want to kill
it then they're all their angry sons
from them being dead are going to be
trying to kill us in new york and you're
like but they are and you keep but maybe
if you just don't kill his dad i'm
thinking like
we might begin the healing process a bit
stop killing everybody's dad
yeah i was going to say you know you
make a good point that hasn't been
drilled into my brain since the time i
was five
that's great is your dad dan crenshaw
don't question my faith little girl
i will [ __ ] bury my fists right in
your bread basket if you're anything if
you're a 12 year old girl or smaller
dan crenshaw is another great example
like he's off limits because he lost an
eye in the line of duty so you can't
ever criticize them and yeah i mean this
is just like a broad principle in
general like david hogg is off limits
because some of his classmates got shot
you know like you can't talk about any
of these people because something bad
happened to them once alex jones we're
allowed to just ruin him and anybody
that says but that's not fair you can't
just that's not how the law works you go
oh so the sandy hook people you're glad
their kids are dead and they're like
nobody said that i'm just saying that
this this a defamation case does not
seem like [ __ ] but you're i know so
so the sandy hook parents should all
just die in the streets homeless no
but i don't think alex jones should have
to give them 170 gajillion billion
dollar like a made-up child number worth
of
money yeah no i mean that's what they
always do is this so what you really
mean is
no if we really meant that we would have
said that that's not what we said [ __ ]
so shut up that's a really good point
honestly especially telling you that
it's like you know if you look at the
libertarian the libertarian party new
hampshire folk and twitter account it's
like um yeah the one thing you can't say
is that they're not direct like you know
what i mean it's like oh you think
they're i don't think i don't look at
that go man i wonder what they really
think over there i'm like oh i know what
they think obviously
so it's exactly it's it's when they put
what what they want on you and the
things you're not allowed to talk about
and i don't you're right it's like there
is certain things that if you bring up
people get really really angry and it's
sacred cows on both sides right they're
sacred cows yeah i mean i grew up in the
bush doctrine era so it was oh so you
hate our troops yeah all right you don't
want to go bomb another country i guess
you hate our troops like i feel like the
opposite is true i feel like i just kind
of tired of seeing them coming home
missing pieces and [ __ ] you know like
well one of one of the guys he's a
libertarian from pennsylvania his name
is kyle matovic he was going through the
replies to that tweet and found a bunch
of conservatives who were denouncing us
as you know disgusting
you know absolutely abhorrent people or
whatever and he'd go search on their
timeline for mean tweets and so he found
like dozens of different examples of
these people saying
wow i could really go for some mean
tweets and better policies right now and
then it's like what the [ __ ] is the
difference here this is a mean tweet and
like if the epitome of mean tweets good
policies libertarian party in new
hampshire like we're way meaner than
trump but we got way better policies
than him too you know it's just like it
just kind of revealed that that is
another false resistance kind of the
whole the whole trump thing yeah they
they yeah they they want they want
[ __ ] daily wire tier [ __ ] boomer
mean tweets they don't want mean tweets
they want they want like oh my god did
he call that girl fat and it's like no
no no no
this twitter over here just said he's
glad megan mccain's [ __ ] war criminal
dad died on his [ __ ] death day how
about that that's mean all right and
it's and it's and obviously you know
like [ __ ] anything on twitter you
they have this like weird policy where
they don't even tell you what the rules
are until you get kicked off well i'm
sure you know
oh yeah i do know
yeah i've been i was there i mean i i
used to have an account like 20 000
followers uh it's almost been a year
since i got
kicked off and it was for just making a
joke with a friend and it was a threat
of violence and you know repealed it
three times had my friend write them
doesn't matter like it's like they're
hovering waiting for you to make a
mistake and then when you finally make a
technical error they're like haha here
we go now we got you it's like a cop
following you for like 10 miles yeah
exactly waiting for you to do just one
thing yeah it's it's it is and this and
there's [ __ ] you know what are they
gonna do but you know again it's it's
like all these people denouncing you i
saw a lot of verified accounts and i'm
like wow you're still around and i'm
like wow this person literally just made
you relevant this tweet made somebody
you made you relevant again just because
you're replying to it it's like say what
the [ __ ] you want but who gives a [ __ ]
like
they they
they they get mad at you being angry but
nobody gets mad at all the [ __ ] 18
year olds who had their [ __ ] arms
blown off and [ __ ] you know it's like
nobody cares about them nobody [ __ ] them
no but somebody somebody was mean to the
[ __ ] narwhal megan mccain oh no
[ __ ] her she just built like a goddamn
linebacker anyway
yeah and dude we made it into national
news for the first time in over two
years by making this tweet and megan
mccain quote tweeted us six times
that was so funny dude she melted the
[ __ ] down that was really [ __ ] funny
that she kept it
she blocked like like you said all the
blue checks coming out of the woodwork
that i didn't i hadn't heard from in
forever and suddenly they come out of
the woodwork to condemn us and uh just
like we saw both right and left wing
come out to call us bad we saw that
equally with right and left wingers
coming out to be like hey [ __ ] the
mccains it was kind of cool you saw like
the hardcore left wingers like caitlyn
johnstone right and uh people like that
and then the hardcore like libertarian
anti-war people kind of coming together
so it was a really interesting moment to
watch
yeah because like you like you were
saying earlier about mean tweets and
everything it's just something that
everybody says nobody means it you know
what you know what i mean
it's like that old mike tyson thing
everybody has a plan to get punch in the
mouth right everyone thinks they're for
really stuff like this shows you who's
for free speech and stuff like that i
saw some [ __ ] libertarian accounts
saying they should delete this i'm like
aren't you supposed to be the freedom
people
yeah
real quick
it was uh it was it was disappointing to
see some people
like say that this is disgusting and
this is worse than what megan mccain did
or you have become the same thing as
megan mccain by doing this i'm like i'm
sorry but making a mean tweet doesn't
make us the same as someone who promotes
war crimes and torture and invading
other countries under false pretenses
that doesn't make us the same i'm sorry
and i'm also sick of this narrative that
with civility we have to be we have to
be civil they wanted to keep some
protesters in jail forever because they
went to the capital that they owned so
don't [ __ ] talk to me about civility
like they always say civilians want you
dead they want you [ __ ] dead they
don't you're exactly they don't give a
[ __ ] about you dude everybody i know
that went like hard right or went like
real crazy right
they all just got broken by like the how
the system changed every one of them had
one thing in common 10 years ago and it
was just i just want you to leave me
alone man like you know what i mean it's
not like you know there were a lot of
people even libertarians are like i'll
compromise i get i can't pay zero
dollars in taxes because we're way too
far beyond going back to that but hey
let's talk about where this money is
going and let's cut back on what you're
taking from me and stop like
indoctrinating my kids and stop like
[ __ ] with my you know messing with my
kids brain and infiltrating churches and
like [ __ ] up with my little community
just leave me alone man i just like the
i just wanted to grill me as one of my
favorite memes of all time because it
really does summarize just that that
kind of rage that's been coming up over
the years where people are like look i
wasn't an angry dude but you have
interrupted me multiple times now and i
just want to grill i just want to be
left alone man i know this might sound
sound kind of selfish but i'm kind of
glad that all the lockdowns and [ __ ]
actually happened because it woke so
many people up to all this [ __ ] that is
already going on like i i remember in
2017 and 2018 and 2019 i was like trying
to tell people like look donald trump is
supporting a genocide in yemen we're
starving you know hundreds of thousands
of babies and women and civilians to
death nobody gave a [ __ ] they're like
okay yemen so what and then when it came
home when it's like you can't leave your
house you need to inject this into your
body suddenly people start to give a
[ __ ] so even though yeah it definitely
like ruined a lot of people's lives
which i'm not minimizing by any stretch
it is a good thing that people are
finally starting to pay attention to how
evil these people are because a lot of
people think they just turned evil like
with the fbi going after trump and [ __ ]
people think oh the fbi just became a
political lynch mob and it's like okay
you don't know about fred hampton you
don't know about uh mlk they tried to
kill mlk like three times and it made it
which is the worst part it's like it
can't they literally admitted it and
everyone's like yeah but the fb that's
why it's like seeing a lot of these same
people that uh i i see i i see like val
dennings is another great example who's
like being the fbi is great you know
screw trump the fbi [ __ ] the other
that's not good i'm like and then she'll
call emma can't be like bro you know the
fbi that like you say you love so much
tried to kill this dude like three times
you know right
yeah no so it's uh
it
it doesn't like hit home until they come
after you and now that they've come
after us hopefully people are going to
remember going forward but i'm sure you
guys agree with me they won't remember
no one remembers [ __ ] nobody ever nobody
cares nobody remembers and you know what
they they count on that i mean at the be
now all these people now now they're
trying to cover their ass about the
vaccine like fouch you're like oh you
never said lockdown and obviously we
know he did but the reality is most
people really don't remember it because
they don't care like again
but i think like you said the lockdown
did expose a lot of that and what it's
you know what's exposing a lot of that
now is when you start realizing like oh
[ __ ] do we have enough food oh [ __ ] do
we have enough gas that's when people
start really going like what the [ __ ]
going on here why is my money worth so
much less you know and that's another
thing is everyone's screaming and biting
about inflation he should be screamed at
partially but they were pretty money
under trump they were pretty [ __ ]
money under obama too like you think the
money just started [ __ ] being printed
under bite and it [ __ ] wasn't well
that's my biggest problem too is like
you know feel i'm feeling how trump
[ __ ] us over yeah and then having
people go we need trump again and i'm
like you do remember trump's the guy
that like let us get locked down and
like started all of this and push the
vaccine and continue to push the back
more money than biden
yeah i'm like honestly i don't know
about that i don't know if he's the
horse i want to back anymore because he
blew it last time
yeah no i mean it's
i'm a bit of an accelerationist as you
can tell from uh the you know the
positivity toward the lockdowns or
whatever but
a hundred percent when it comes to
having a
tyrant in charge i prefer a transparent
tyrant so i actually like i think it's
great that biden's in there because he's
so bad like even the democrats have
trouble defending him they're like uh
they're like are you gonna vote for him
again in 2024 and every single one of
them is like well
if the president decides to run again
you know that's his choice yeah that's
not what i asked are you going to vote
for him again well you know the voters
are going to have to just yeah that's
not what i asked you know they came bro
that's exactly what nadler did when they
asked him it was hilarious he was like
well that's not what's important right
now that's not what's important right
now i'm like yeah no but like it takes
one second to answer that like just
[ __ ] answer it so okay this is
something that i i think is and and i'm
sure something else you're probably
happy about
seeing all the republicans for so many
years were thin blue lining and [ __ ]
bootlicking cops and being cops are so
[ __ ] awesome and cops are great and
then realizing that when the [ __ ] tie
turns they're the ones they're going to
take your [ __ ] the other ones are going
to lock you up the other ones are going
to shoot ashley babbitt in the face
um and and i think that there is a big
shift going on with that i think there's
a lot of less
of those
thin blue line stuff when now the cops
are realizing look they're just an arm
of the government it's whoever's in
charge is going to aim them at whoever
they want because they have a pension
yeah i'm hoping that that is true i mean
i i think people have like hoped a
little too hard on that being true and
it's not been as a systemic change as we
hope but i am starting to see it with a
lot of people i know they're starting to
realize like hmm
uh maybe it's not going to be aoc and
nancy pelosi walking up my driveway to
take my guns that's just going to be a
red flag order that a judge signs and
the local police come and kick down my
door and take it and then
it wasn't like
you know
jerry nadler and chris cuomo were
walking around and like actually making
sure we didn't come out of our houses
during lockdowns that was the police who
were doing that
so yeah i think there has been a shift
you know as the democrats have gotten
worse on war the republicans have gotten
better on uh police so you know take
whatever trends we can i guess i never
win anything so just
push people in the right direction hey
hold on buddy you're saying joe
jorgensen wasn't the [ __ ] best oh my
god
you know it's so funny though when like
when [ __ ] hits the fan when it's
something i don't care about like i
really don't care about roe v wade
that's just something that's not i'm not
like super hard-lined on it either way
right but seeing everybody flip the [ __ ]
out when that got overturned i was like
i never win anything like nothing that i
want to see happen
ever happens so when i see trump win and
people flip out or trump lose and people
flip out or you know uh roe v wade get
overturned and people flip out like i
love it because it's like you guys get
to feel how i feel for once this is how
i feel all the time so is it i you just
gotta like kind of you know get all the
energy out of those moments and that's
what i kind of live off at this point i
mean it's it's very similar to you know
it's going back i think you're right
about the lockdown like
um it's it's really exposing um a lot of
flaws and and a lot of the things
because i think that at least like for
example me for example
i don't really care that much like you
know if you're gonna push me i'll tell
you my opinion but i'm not someone who's
out there screaming about pro-life or
pro-choice either but for me the reason
i was screaming and laughing and having
such a good time was a lot of these
people that were saying my body my
choice my body my choice for telling me
to take a shot that i don't want to
[ __ ] take or wear a mask or i lose my
[ __ ] job so then when it happened to
them i'm sorry i'm human i loved it i
loved it i'm like what happened you
don't like the government telling you
what you could do with your body [ __ ]
sucks right
i enjoyed it a little bit yeah a little
bit yeah it was one of those was like it
was yeah okay on principle no but i was
like hey you know what
a [ __ ] turnabout is fair play
[ __ ] you know yeah
no i i feel the same way it's also funny
like going back to the debates in 2016
and seeing trump say like you know we
need to close down certain sections of
the internet and you can talk about
freedom of speech all you want but you
know some of these people are just
dangerous and we can't have our young
people listening to them and it's like
the exact [ __ ] excuse they use to
kick him off social media exactly
exactly what i wanted it's just like
jesus christ do you guys ever [ __ ]
learn and another perfect example what
was what was the trump quote about
taking guns merchants uh
okay yeah can we just take their guns
and we'll figure it out yeah or whatever
due process yeah second due process
later it's like yeah
and and again it's like the same thing
with me i argue with people but i always
say the same thing it's like bro he
brought john bolton in on purpose
like and look i'm sorry don't tell me
there was no red flags with that like
come on you can't drain a swamp unless
you dredge it first oh you gotta make
the swamp deeper and then i don't know
somehow you make america better
yeah no i mean i
see like there's this
some people want desantis some people
want trump i don't have much faith in
either of them but i actually think
trump has more likelihood of helping us
out than desantis does because desantis
i think is more of an establishment
person who pretends he isn't where trump
is he was he's just an idiot i don't
think trump is like legit of
like a war hawk or
a zionist or uh like i don't think he
really likes saudi arabia i don't think
he really cares he's just he doesn't
know [ __ ] and he gets in there and these
people are like all right do this now do
this oh we'll let you hold our sword and
touch our [ __ ] ball of saruman thing
if you do this like that
so weird dude that picture dude what is
that
dude what is that [ __ ] thing yeah
like yeah honestly what is that yeah
honestly i want to know
like i don't know why every president
has to go and touch it like it's the
[ __ ] stanley cup
i mean every president like that has to
put their hand what is that here i'll
pull it up for you hold on hold on like
if i weren't listen if i were part of
them what the [ __ ] man
if i were an elected official
right and they said hey mr president
before you leave we got to do the globe
photo op right i'd go
yeah i just feel like optics wise this
isn't going to be great i don't like the
way that looks so i'm going to pass but
then none of them ever pass right right
so something's weird because any normal
person nobody would pose he's not
passing but you look at that picture you
could tell he loves this yeah he's like
what i've been waiting for my whole life
i'm touching the globe
folks you know what i did love about
trump though is i remember when we you
know repositioned troops on the border
of syria so we wouldn't get into a war
with turkey and it was deemed
abandoning the kurds and pulling out of
syria even though that's like not what
what happened at all but um he said
we're going to leave a detachment of
troops behind to protect the oil and
people flipped the [ __ ] at him for
saying that and i was like yeah that's
awful that you know you know syria is
its own country and we're just going to
keep troops there and take their oil
from them but at least he's like saying
why we're actually there you know like
why we're actually keeping the troops
there it's not
to protect people from assad or some
[ __ ] that you've come up with like
that is why we kept troops there so i i
just the accidental slips of honesty
here and there when he was president i
did love those moments well you know you
know it's funny you say that because we
talk about on the show all the time like
i would never vote for bernie sanders i
hate all probably almost all his
policies however that being said bernie
sanders doesn't bother me
as much as as like a dan crenshaw he
gives an example because bernie sanders
is at least telling you to your [ __ ]
face what he you know what i mean he's
saying like no no i'm going to raise
taxes no no no no that's what i'm doing
okay and and you're like okay you know
what at least it's somebody that's
telling me the truth when a lot of the
times a lot of these guys run and they
say oh no i'm not you know i'm a patriot
and they come and they spend the same
[ __ ] amount of money but instead of
sending it to to to to [ __ ] to the
irs or sending it to ukraine which
honestly are both useless
yeah i mean i i understand what you're
saying i think bernie is just as much of
a sellout to his supporters as like
crenshaw would be to us though because
bernie talks like he's anti-corporate
he's anti-war he's anti-all this [ __ ]
but then he [ __ ] votes for the cares
act he votes for a good point you know
the bailout of 2020 like all this [ __ ]
so i i get what you're saying like
people on the left probably say the same
thing about christmas
they're probably like at least crenshaw
tells you he believes in small
government and we're over here like the
[ __ ] like he does
you know it's kind of funny good point
that's actually a really good point i
guess it's all perspective right yeah
shout out to the world economic forum
and now that being right we do have we
talk all of this and then we go really
quick we have to talk about our sponsor
goldman sachs can you imagine how funny
that would be
all right guys let me tell you about the
federal reserve and how cool it is
oh [ __ ] um so yeah so uh i mean okay so
what what what do you what you sent me
some stuff so
what what are you what are you working
on
yeah so i um i i don't i i missed like
the intro i got or whatever that you
said you said so i'm uh i'm a podcaster
truck driver uh and i was living out in
utah moving lots of heavy equipment but
i'm from new hampshire and i decided to
move
back to new hampshire after the last
couple years
just because
you know i've realized that lie that
libertarians have always told that most
people are libertarian but they don't
know it yet it's just [ __ ] most
people
are not libertarian they're never going
to be libertarian regardless they're
never going to be logically argued into
libertarianism like they like either
being told what to do so they don't have
to think or they like bossing people
around the people who just want to look
after themselves
are few and far between so i decided
look new hampshire has the free state
project and enough people have been
kicked out of their uh or not kicked out
of their houses locked in their houses
kicked out of their jobs and they've
finally been like okay i guess now is a
good enough time to head to new
hampshire because i like what they're
doing and we've had the biggest influx
of free staters ever in the last couple
years and now free staters hold a strong
minority in the new hampshire house and
senate so basically the free staters
control what ends up being passed in the
state because like if you're a
libertarian as you know like the biggest
thing isn't about what you can pass it's
what you can stop from being passed and
there's right almost nothing
that we don't like that gets passed and
then we're actually finally at the point
where we're starting to be able to dis
uh you know dismembered uh laws that
have already been put in place or
whatever
and um yeah we're you know we've like
nullified all gun laws so it doesn't
really matter what the president and the
house and senate do no local law
enforcement is going to be required to
enforce those laws um we're working on
decentralizing a lot of things like
right now if
even if we get a democrat governor in
new hampshire they can't do a statewide
lockdown anymore that's done on a town
by town basis and pretty much every town
in new hampshire would be like [ __ ] you
um and as you can see from our messaging
on our twitter platform we're really
trying to uh you know we're really
trying to embarrass people who are from
new hampshire who don't share of our
values we're basically trying to be like
if you're a conservative from san
francisco you're embarrassed to admit
you're from san francisco or if you're a
liberal from florida same thing we're
kind of trying to create that in new
hampshire
like we don't you know we're not going
to build a wall between us and
massachusetts but we could just be
obnoxiously pro-liberty pro-gun
pro-individualism and people will
uh voluntarily leave and they won't want
to come so it's it's finally starting to
actually take off because of the tyranny
of the last two years we should do
something like that with new yorkers in
florida i need these [ __ ] out of here
like i cannot
i cannot stand in ontario oh my god the
[ __ ] snowbirds
they need to [ __ ] leave i agree so
haven't you to an extent though like
aren't they kind of repulsed by moving
there at this point or is it have you
not seen it you know you know what it is
it's somebody who's like it's you know
what you know new yorkers are and i
figured it out it's like somebody that
would like we would be running like a
healthy a healthy
vegan plant-based youtube channel but as
soon as they're off the camera they're
eating junk food and [ __ ]
that's what new yorkers are they talk
[ __ ] about florida but at the end of the
day they really don't want to wear masks
they just want a virtue signal in the
upper west side and say they do right
they really actually want to go to
disney world they don't want to be on a
crowded subway they want to [ __ ] be
here and be able to like you know and
and not have to [ __ ] worry if you're
asian that you're going to get [ __ ]
uppercutted for walking into a store
they've really been a suspiciously dark
white supremacist officially dark white
supremacist
so
um i did but but so they want it but
it's like they're ashamed to admit that
they like it it's a weird thing and by
the way they'll still vote like [ __ ]
lefty new york idiots that's the other
thing because they have to be able to
say that but they love all the [ __ ]
freedom and all that [ __ ] here trust me
man look there's there's a lot there
there's there's a
you and i have a different reason why
you don't want the sanders to run i
don't want them to run because i don't
want i want the [ __ ] state governor
here for i don't want to lose him sure
because he got rid of the [ __ ] i
understand that perspective by the way
like
him as governor is very different than
him as president right very different
scenario right he [ __ ] he [ __ ] so he
got the mass taken off of airplanes you
know like he took he took that away from
biden which i thought was nice because
i'm sure that's something i don't want
to be like and today we're announcing
we're taking it's like like i think two
weeks before he's like no no no santa's
did that
you can't
but but i i think that that's how it is
with a lot of people i think that
all these people talk [ __ ] but i saw a
stat today i think it was 28
of address changes at the you know dmv
since the beginning of the pandemic were
changed to florida addresses florida's
going to have
845 new people every single day for the
next three years and trust me i know
because i'm in the middle of trying to
move and trying to find a place and we
were talking about that before the show
and royce is like oh yeah you're [ __ ]
i'm like lethal you need to leave i
don't want any more of you because you
know sometimes a lot of people like well
i don't care if you come if you i don't
even care if you feel like a leader
[ __ ] leave i can't drive as long as
you're spending money here i don't i
don't need your money go
yeah that's why i couldn't do florida
like i i mean i i don't mind the
politics that are taking place for the
most part there but uh
i like mountains and i like snow
florida doesn't have either so new
hampshire it is
but that's actually cool that you guys
did something about it like that that's
actually like i honestly didn't know
that much because obviously you know you
don't when you don't live in a state you
know you kind of tangentially know
what's going on but you really don't but
that's actually pretty cool you know
that that you know you a lot of people
talk [ __ ] but you guys are actually like
no no we're gonna [ __ ] do now no we
keep now we're gonna show you what we're
gonna do you know yeah and i mean you
know what for further for the most part
um i don't know man it's like i i was
immersed and i guess both were big 2012
ron paul guys right like that was always
it and then you're like you're like
anything like okay that was the dream
man that was [ __ ] dream bro remember
arresting people for printing silver
coins with his face on him that was
awesome
but it's it's i think somewhere along
the way and you were talking about it
earlier the libertarian party really
lost its way like it was it became like
a joke if we're being honest right like
when you're like
oh okay what what is this what's going
on and and how did you guys deal with
that pushback from the old guard
well people were just fed up because
like i uh i mean i remember in 2016 i
was a rand paul supporter and he is not
his dad like i mean don't get me wrong
he's good on a lot of stuff like fouchy
and most of the war stuff and everything
but he's just not his dad he's not
nearly as principal not nearly as
exciting to listen to
and he you know he just lost and so then
i did end up voting for gary johnson but
it was pretty tepid vote wasn't very
excited about it and bill weld sucked i
didn't even realize at the time that he
was like a raytheon
um
[ __ ] what
he worked for raytheon in some capacity
i forget what it was at some point
by the way isn't very libertarian
i don't know if you guys know that or
not he likes softly endorsed hillary
clinton later on in the campaign like
it's just awful and then uh 2020
um
same thing like i mean i'm friends with
spike cohen i do like him i think he's
pretty good he was the vice prince
presidential candidate but yeah joe
jorgensen man she just
she was pretty good on the issues but
man like the stuff she focused on i was
like why are you talking about this
right now like why are you talking about
being so anti-racist or whatever the
[ __ ] when we're being locked in our
houses and they're taking
trillions of our dollars and bailing out
corporations and giving it to foreign
countries and [ __ ] like you know it
seems like lockdowns and
corporatism should be like at the top of
the list of the things we're talking
about right now and then like all the
riots going on you know self-defense
yeah uh property rights like there's so
many inns that were just missed and uh
dave smith who's kind of become the new
face of the libertarian party like he
was really hitting home runs on what we
should be talking about all the time and
uh i think he's probably gonna run for
president he's heavily considering it
and uh he's gonna hopefully kind of
bring that new
face of you know uh understanding what's
important at the given time of what we
should be [ __ ] talking about and what
what hills are worth dying on too you
know like it's okay to be an extremist
if you choose your battles like we're
extremely anti-war extremely
anti-federal reserve extremely
anti-police state anti-war on drugs and
we can argue about like privatizing the
sidewalks later like that's not like the
[ __ ] most important thing right now
you know i'll you know i really do like
that though because thank you that's
like at least you you just like let's
see the stuff that we could actually do
you know what i mean that's we were
joking just the other day on this show
about that about how they're like you
know i'm like the country's on fire
there's no baby formula there's an
energy crisis i mean we're just inflate
like we're literally going to the 1970s
all over again and the president just
goes on tv and it's like we're not being
nice enough to gay people
no you're right honestly we haven't
given them enough attention or been nice
enough to them that's why we're having
all these biblical problems
can they just stop being so nice with
kids
um
that's a
no but it's it's true it's it's like
it's the focuses are always like dude
there's sure we could do [ __ ] right
now
and it's always like no [ __ ] no gas
cars by 2035 you're like really that's
what's important right now really
yeah yeah and then dude the republicans
like seeing yes they're because they
should be this should be the easiest
silver platter for them in history like
hey we need to stop spending money and
we need to end this war in ukraine and
we need to like start caring about our
own people again instead you know trump
gives his speech a few weeks ago and
he's like we need to execute drug
dealers and we need to make sure our
enemies fear us and it's like
dude what like that's what you got for
us are you [ __ ] kidding me so yeah
the republicans aren't going to help us
either so oh no libertarians they've got
a huge [ __ ] opportunity coming up and
i think they could really capitalize on
it
look man i'm a big proponent of like
what marx was saying earlier
when it's all when you boil everything
down to it
just [ __ ] leave me alone
and and and i think that and i'll leave
you alone and i'll leave you with that's
exactly right and i'll leave that's the
other part of that deal yeah it's fine
but but the problem is is that neither
side just wants to [ __ ] leave you
alone because i will i will agree with
you how many times all these
conservatives are like oh look at them
canceling people look at them canceling
people but then the moment like a lefty
does they do the same thing
they do the same thing and they never
like take apart the structure that is
crushing them you know right it's like
look guys if you had really gone after
the fbi when you owned everything when
you were in the the white house the
house and senate you know you could have
done something but you didn't and now
you're paying for it and i guarantee you
like next time they're in charge they're
gonna do the same thing just they'll
switch the people out and then those
people can just get switched out again
and everything's gonna stay the same
okay i'm going to ask you a question but
i have to specif only because today's
episode is on youtube if not i would i
wouldn't put this little preface only
because we've got paid before but what
is your sure what is your favorite and
by favorite i mean did you think more
the most plausibility to conspiracy
theory that is not medical based
because no i'm sorry i have to say that
only because that's what they're waiting
for that's what they're hitting us
they're hitting all of us with those
strikes so my most plausible conspiracy
right that's not medical based correct
um i think let's see most plausible um
what's considered a conspiracy theory
i actually saw somebody tweet that out
they go hey does anybody got any new
conspiracy theories because all of them
might keep true fresh out is operation
timber sycamore a conspiracy theory
still you know like arming isis and al
qaeda in syria like i think that's
[ __ ] true i would i would say uh yeah
i'm friends with ryan dawson and uh yeah
quite a bit and we uh we talked about
911 and the saudi israeli and u.s
intelligence agency involvement in 911
and i think that that that's an area
where you have like where like i was
talking earlier you got an intentional
narrative and an intentional counter
narrative and they're both [ __ ] and
the truth is a bit more complicated in
the middle and so i i think at a bare
minimum the israelis the saudis and the
u.s intelligence agencies all knew it
was going to happen
probably helped it happen and then
obviously [ __ ] raped the benefits of
it afterwards or in my opinion or at
worst let it even if they let's say if
you don't believe they helped it they
let it you know what i mean absolutely
no doubt which is just as bad but but
that that is absolutely one where where
i think the reason that that one got
like so like oh my god those crazy it's
we always talk about in the show one of
the best tactics to get rid of plausible
questions you have is throw crazy
conspiracies together and they mush them
together and then it's like all of you
are crazy you know all of you are
are nuts that's not what happened but
you're like no no hold on but there is
some stuff that you do ask it's like you
know i'm sorry but there's no way the
intelligence they just didn't [ __ ]
know what was going on and then you know
if you really want to get into it tower
7 is a fun one you know obviously
and and then you start and and you start
asking questions because the problem
people always still have this this and i
think it might be said earlier like
super naive right like they always go
the government will never do that and
you're always like that will smith mean
when you're like
yeah look at all this other [ __ ] what
about all this
the uh what you're talking about is
disinformation what it actually means i
had yeah i talked to ben swann about
this once he was like uh you know
disinformation's a word we hear all the
time now but what it really means is
when intelligence agencies or whatever
purposefully inject ridiculous stories
into the mix to discredit the truth so
you have this is another like epstein is
another thing i'm kind of into and like
with pizzagate you have the same deal
like it just got cookified and turned
ridiculous about like uh you know
drinking the blood of children in
basements and you know like just people
don't even want to hear anything about
it and they're like well what about the
les wexner foundation their connections
to epstein you know they're
the iraq war and you know like all this
[ __ ] it's like that's all probably true
and just because this [ __ ]
ridiculous story was pushed out in front
of it nobody wants to hear it anymore
that's a hundred percent how it works
and then like the medical things you
were talking about it's you believe a
hundred percent of it or you don't
believe any of it there's no room for
nuance so they put you in like either
denier or confirmer camp on everything
across the board and there's just like
no nuance at all it's kind of like how
the pentagon lost two trillion dollars
before 9 11. and everyone's like hey we
going to talk about that
anyone no no i guess not okay whatever
we're going to talk about because now
we're stuck with pete davidson yeah
that's the worst thing about 911
911 is [ __ ] pete davidson that is the
[ __ ] worst thing and look i don't
care how big that guy's dick is okay
there's [ __ ] enough of that guy all
right
what's your favorite pete davidson
sketch i'm kidding i'm kidding
yeah i can't think of one
oh [ __ ]
man uh
yeah dude what any what else you want to
plug we're coming up here towards the
end of the show so like what what else
besides the of course which i just put
it on the uh
fsp.org all right liberty lives in new
hampshire uh anything else you want to
plug that's coming up
yeah just uh
go on youtube and uh type in war is gay
and you'll get the jared kaufman ad it's
absolutely incredible uh that's the guy
we're running for senate right now i
think you said that to me hold on let me
go ahead you can play it if you want
it's only like a minute okay i will it's
[ __ ] worth it all right this is our
guy running for us senate from the
libertarian party of new hampshire
all right let's see war is gay all right
let's see
hold on
i mean i already like the title so okay
here it is
picture this
innocent people in the middle east
they're having dinner
a bomb is dropped on their house
and they're all killed
what's the problem with this
it's being done by white men
i am jeremy kaufman the chief diversity
officer at halliburton
and candidate for the united states
it is time to diversify the murderous
military industrial complex amen we need
to make the nukes gay
like my fellow democrats and republicans
i will support every war i will support
stealing billions of dollars from
americans to kill innocent people but we
are going to make it so
gay it will go down in the history books
we will say never have so many genders
and so many races killed innocent people
let's bomb yemen
but let's make sure a rainbow of skin
colors are dropping those bombs
these are going to be the gayest
transist murders the united states has
ever performed in person that's what i
stand for as the chief diversity officer
at halliburton and that's what i'll do
once elected to the united states senate
i'm jeremy kaufman and i'm gay for this
message
this is really well done bro
dude the best part of that was and we're
gonna make it so okay
so okay this is [ __ ] crazy
vote like your pride depends on it
this is brilliantly done bro this is
[ __ ] really good exactly it's just
reality now though i know but it's so
funny you can't even do parody anymore
because you're like yeah this is funny
but it's like he's just like
exaggerating what's really happening
anyway yeah it's not even really an
exaggeration like sometimes i'm
subscribing
oh yeah yeah so that's uh jeremy kaufman
just go to
jeremy4newhampshire.com that's the
number four
um and you can check out his campaign
there he officially made it on the
ballot which we have to petition for
every year because we don't have party
access because we're a third party or
whatever but uh
yeah the likelihood is the republican is
gonna suck just as much as the incumbent
uh democrat so uh we're just gonna push
the overton window as we do
[ __ ] man this is this is a lot of fun uh
so [ __ ] funny man yeah
that was really it was [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] really really good [ __ ]
um but uh yeah man thank you so much for
being on i appreciate it yeah we gotta
have you on again you're welcome on
whenever you want
i know hey i had done a show with you in
clip before i remember now right yeah
tower gang yeah
that's what it was yeah that was fun
i was hungover as [ __ ] so i was like i
was like boy if he remembers me might
not want to have me on the show because
i just kind of sat there in the
background like
sort of zoning it out
it was a it was a fun week we're up at
pork fest in new hampshire right drunk
so yeah not
dude please give me a break every time i
interview libertarian i'm assuming
either hung over or we're about to be
hungover
so it's like doing a show with with
merch every day
um
but uh yeah man hey by the way
tell dave smith to do our show i've been
trying to reach out to him all right i
already did lewis has already done our
show he always gets done on our show oh
you guys have done to show you he's just
he's big league in us yeah
everybody with political aspirations
somebody wants to come up with a shout
out come on our show no more nicki free
packed out really hard if he runs yeah
nikki nikki freed's a coward i think he
freaks a [ __ ] coward she ran from us
she did she said she was gonna do the
show and then she goes oh no you're
friendly with alex jones i can't do your
show like that's why women lose because
they're scared
uh [ __ ] yeah cause apparently if
you're friends with people that are nice
to you that's a [ __ ] you're not
allowed to be friends with people you
just you are the person that's nice to
you you've been nice to them back you're
[ __ ] black you're [ __ ] ass i guess
hey thanks so much man we we we really
do appreciate you welcome on whenever
you like just let us know alright thanks
yeah just uh naturalist capitalist is my
podcast i'm sure you already plugged it
just google that i'm the only one and
i'm the only read covered l so you'll
find me everywhere there you go all
right man take it easy really appreciate
it all right thanks guys it was fun yeah
thanks man there goes reid he was most
fun that was a lot it was a lot of fun